- Yoo-hoo.
I got an idea, feel free to say no,
but can we switch seats?
I will not take no for an answer.
- Why?
- That's the combat seat,
Jonathan Livingston Seagull.
If you're gonna be in the combat seat,
then you gots to be willing
to blast up on some terries.
Because with great power comes
great resbronsatrilities.
(guitar music)
- Good morning, ladies and gentlemen.
We are about to begin boarding
South Northern Airlines,
flight 34 to Grand Rapids.
- Okay, excuse me, boarding group one.
I'm in boarding group one, excuse me,
I'm in boarding group one.
- And...
We would like to begin pre-boarding
with our first class passengers.
First class passengers only, please.
Next, our business class
passengers may now board.
Okay, now we would like to welcome
our Regal Alliance Elite members.
Regal Alliance Elite members.
Okay, now all passengers with children.
Anyone with small children,
you may board now.
(baby cries)
Okay, we would like to continue boarding
with uniformed military personnel.
- What?
Why...?
This is...
Thank you for your service.
Thank you so much for your
service, God bless you.
- Thank you for your service.
Thank you for your service.
All right, people in wheelchairs.
Any priests, nuns, rabbis, imams.
- What?
Why do they get special treatment?
- As-Salaam-Alaikum.
- I've never...
That's typical.
- Any old people in
wheelchairs with babies.
(baby cries)
Any old religious people
with military babies.
- What's a military...?
- Thank you for your service.
Jason Schwartzman.
Anyone with a blue
suitcase, you may now board.
- Finally.
- Nope, not you, sir.
- Not me?
This is a blue suitcase.
- That's a blue computer bag.
- So you're not gonna let me on then.
Dammit!
Dammit, dammit, dammit, dammit, dammit!
Goddammit!
- Anyone who doesn't seem cranky.
Drunk people.
We will now be boarding any drunk people.
- All right.
No, it's my bag.
Sir.
(phone rings)
- Ooh.
Hello?
Oh, hey, Christian.
Yeah.
Totally.
Well, you have your favorites
and I have my favorites.
Okay.
Call you later.
Cow-cow.
Boarding group one.
(orchestral music)
- Anybody seen Jason Schwartzman?
Jason Schwartzman!
Pick up your hand!
We gotta find Jason!
- I got him!
I got Schwartzman here!
- Hey, everyone!
Jason Schwartzman's fine!
(people cheer)
- We got Jason Schwartzman,
let's wrap it up, people.
- Boarding group one over here!
Boarding group on!
(plane rattles)
- And he talks too much.
That's why I like you, you don't talk,
you just listen.
(intercom beeps)
And the captain has turned
on the fasten seatbelt sign.
Got a little turbulence coming up,
should be no problem,
just remain in your seat
until the sign is turned off.
Thank you for your cooperation.
Okay.
- Excuse me, I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
(intense music)
- Hi, excuse me.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
I'm gonna need you to take your seat,
the fasten seatbelt sign is on.
- I'm just gonna go to
the bathroom for a second,
I'll be right back, okay?
- I understand what you wanna do.
Unfortunately, I'm gonna need you
to observe the fasten seatbelt sign.
That'd be much appreciated.
- Right, it's just I read on the internet
that it's not against the law
for me to go to the bathroom
while the fasten seatbelt sign is on, so.
- Seatbelt sign is on.
- But is it against the law though?
- The light is on.
- Is it against the law?
- You see that there's a picture
of a seatbelt on that sign.
- I know, but is it
against the law though?
- The fasten seatbelt sign is on.
- But is it against the law though?
- The seatbelt sign's on.
- But is it against the law?
- The seatbelt sign is on.
- Seatbelt sign.
- But is it against the law?
- It's on.
- The law.
- Seatbelt sign is on.
- Legal.
- Law form.
- Seatbelt sign is on.
- Law.
- Sir, you're being difficult.
You're being very difficult.
- Law, law.
- Law, law, law.
- Seatbelt, seatbelt.
Seatbelt.
- Not illegal.
Not illegal.
- Seatbelt.
- Not illegal.
- Okay.
- Legal.
Legal.
- Fasten your seatbelt.
- Legal.
- Sir!
- I have to piss and I have to (bleeps)
in the toilet.
- Sir,
can you lower your voice?
- I have to piss and I have to (bleeps).
- Okay, lower your intensity.
- You're louder than me.
- You're yelling in my face.
- Sir, you're the one that
needs to tone it down right now.
You are screaming at me.
- You're hurting my eardrums.
That wasn't a word, you're
not saying a word there.
- This is a word.
- That's not.
- That's a word.
- That's not a word,
that's a tongue trick.
Okay, sir, sir, sir.
If you would like...
- I would not like to.
I would not like to sit down.
What I'd like to do
is go take a (bleeps) in the bathroom.
Because it's not against the law.
So I'm gonna go to the bathroom.
Okay?
Mark.
With a K.
(intense music)
(seatbelt clicks)
(plane rattles)
(passengers gasp)
(passengers scream)
(plane rattles)
(plane beeps)
(intense music)
(seatbelt clicks)
Whoo.
- And your captain has turned
off the fasten seatbelt sign.
Feel free to move around the cabin.
Thank you for your cooperation.
- Excuse me.
Oh, excuse me, sir,
are you sitting in 26G?
- Yes.
Have I done something wrong?
- No, no, no, no,
we just wanted to ask if you
would mind switching seats
so that a mother and a
child could sit together?
- But,
I'm back there.
- Right, yeah,
but you'd actually be sitting here.
(harp music)
Which is in economy plus.
It's actually an upgrade.
- Upgrade, you say?
- Mm-hmm.
- Economy plus?
- Yes, sir.
- Oh.
Don't mind if I do.
- Great, great, carryon?
- Carryon yourself, Alex.
- Thank you.
(orchestral music)
- Economy plus.
Mm, for the discerning passenger.
(man chuckles)
We're not in Kansas anymore.
Toto.
- [Captain] Ladies and gentlemen,
this is your captain speaking.
We should be leaving Topeka
in the next 10 minutes.
- I stand corrected.
- [Captain] Looks like we're
gonna have a smooth flight.
Trust me, I know the captain,
and he's one smooth guy.
(both chuckle)
(man laughs maniacally)
- Of course he knows the captain.
He is the captain!
Oh!
Oh, move over, Colin Mockery,
there's a new face in the biz.
His name is Captain.
(man giggles)
You have to be in economy
plus to get it, I guess.
Ah.
Extra foot room.
One inch at least.
Mm.
Sky Shoppe magazine.
Don't mind if I do.
Oh, dog eared for my convenience.
"Lord of the Rings" cups.
"Lord of the Rings" tables.
Oh, oh!
Holy shiatsu massage!
Oh!
Economy plus!
It hurts a little, but I like it.
(man laughs insanely)
Rosebud.
(man snores)
(thunder rumbles)
(eerie music)
(creature growls)
Hmm.
And I thought I had an upgrade.
- Yo.
Hey, yo.
Yo, yo.
- Excuse me?
- Oh, man, oh, man, oh, man.
I tell you one thing,
if 9/11's were'st to happen
up on this here plane,
don't worry, we got this.
- Oh, okay, I have no idea
what you're talking about.
- He said that if them terries
is gonna try something up in here today
like the bounce, boogie, and bump,
that we got (bleeps) on lock.
- Do you mean terrorists?
- Oh, yeah.
- Hell yeah, baby.
He ain't talking about Teri Garr.
- And I certainly ain't
talking about no Terry Claus.
I mean, if a terry up on this plane
even thinking about
trying to do something,
we gon' draxx him up.
- You're gonna what?
- We gonna draxx
them sklounst.
- I think what my partner is trying to say
is if any terries come up in here,
we gon' get our Bergeron.
Yeah.
- Did something happen,
or did I miss something?
Is this a hypothetical, or...?
- Oh, we gon' definitely
drop some hypotheticals
on that terry's clavicle
'cause I'm talking about psh!
Squeeze, squeeze, squeeze, squeeze!
Skrrt, skrrt, skrrt, skrrt!
- Don't you just wish though,
don't you just wish in
your heart of hearts
some terry would come up in here
trying some grabass and the touchy-feely?
- That's the opposite of
what I want to have happen
on a plane.
- Okay, that's unfortunate.
Conference.
- This was unexpected.
- Certainly was.
I'm thrown right now
as to who's gonna be
our comrade in this...
- I can still hear you.
- He doesn't have the
heart nor the gumption.
- You're literally right next to me, so.
- On three, break.
Three.
Yoo-hoo.
I got an idea, feel free to say no,
but can we switch seats?
I will not take no for an answer.
- Why?
- That's the combat seat,
Jonathan Livingston Seagull.
If you gonna be in the combat seat,
then you gots to be willing
to blast up on some terries.
Because with great power comes
great resbronsatrilities.
- Okay, I just wanted some leg room.
- Okay, Max Leg Room.
You'll get yours.
Meanwhile, I'm gonna go Hayden
Panteniere on some terries,
especially when they get froggy.
- Ribbit, ribbit.
- Um.
- You're gonna have to be
ready to kidnap a terry.
- I don't...
- You're gonna have to be
ready to torture a terry.
- I don't think that's necessary.
- Absolutely, you have
fireboard those motherjammers.
- I don't even understand what that means.
- Do you trust me?
- No.
- I'll take that as a yes.
- Okay.
- Trust,
these terries come up in
here trying to act froggy...
- Then we gonna give them
the rainbow connection.
- Here, froggy, froggy, froggy, froggy.
- A box cutter?
- Oh, you best believe it, baby.
We gonna be eating like Diane Keaton.
2.36 inches, baby.
- Sure facts.
- Perfectly legal.
- And if those don't work,
you know I'm working up
that plan B, brother.
- You have a gun?!
- Hell yeah.
3D printer, baby.
100% polyurethane.
They can't detect these mammajammas.
- They have a weapon, they have a weapon!
He's got a weapon!
- Where you at, terry?
(passengers scream)
Everybody relax, we taking
control of this plane!
(all yell)
Get out of the way, it's the ringleader!
- No, no, no, no, no, no!
I'm on vacation!
(soft music)
- Draxx
them sklounst.
(whimsical music)